as the carnage continues in afghanistan
we need to ask if our leaders are in
over their heads do they have an
evacuation plan are they even aware of
how many americans are left on the
ground
how many americans american citizens
remain in
in afghanistan i don't know
well i guess that's a no
but what about our commander-in-chief
does joe biden understand what the
taliban are after
what happens now in afghanistan do you
believe the taliban have changed
no
i think let me put this way
i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized
by the international communities being a
legitimate government
an existential crisis kind of like
growing pains this is the same
bloodthirsty militant group we've always
known no matter what their pr push shows
it was funny watching them joyride and
bumper cars but that's not who they are
oh by the way as we mentioned earlier
after they shot that video they burned
down the amusement park that's the real
taliban actually violence against human
beings is the real taliban now let me
bring in marine corps combat that jesse
kelly retired army ranger and former
obama campaign director robin bairo
thank you both for being with me uh
jesse do you have faith that the taliban
has changed they're going through some
existential crisis
oh absolutely well you see these guys
have seen the error of their ways i mean
by tomorrow there'll be schools for
women in afghanistan
honestly we are a country run by
children biden the entire administration
were run by a bunch of academics who've
never spent five minutes in the actual
real world they went right from the
college campus into government somehow
and that's the only way anyone on the
planet could be stupid enough to think
the taliban have somehow changed their
ways or they're having a crisis or or
they're worried about an economy you
have to have the brain function of a
dung beetle like biden does to actually
believe that robin do you think the
taliban has changed
no and they never will they are in over
their head what president biden said was
basically a polite way of saying that
they don't deserve politeness the
taliban will never change i didn't
believe for a second when they said they
were going to be kinder to women because
the very next day they arrested and
detained the female governor a female
governor there in afghanistan you can
never take these people for their word i
was nervous when our former president
invited them to camp david uh i don't
trust them at all well then robin i have
to follow up with then why is the biden
administration attempting to trust or
plead with the taliban to get the 15 000
americans behind enemy lines safely to
the airport if everyone on this panel
and in your estimation joe biden as well
agrees that the taliban cannot be
trusted why are we placing so much trust
in the taliban
whatever it takes will to get americans
home safely american soldiers
it's not going to work with pleading
with the taliban to do this we're going
to have a firm extrication plan uh this
is on the joint chiefs of staff and the
secretary secretary of defense i
personally want to see some some more
from secretary of state blinken where
has he been in all of this you know
jesse i can't help but be revolted quite
honestly at the idea that everything
we're discussing here was quote priced
into the calculation chaos
set aside jesse right how many blackhawk
helicopters rifles aircraft night vision
goggles billions that we've left for
them to use or sell set that aside the
15 000 americans were priced into this
chaos
no it wasn't priced and it wasn't
planned out because this administration
doesn't do anything really thinking
about america everything is geared about
politics that's the problem will they
knew we had american citizens there when
they knew we had thousands of them we
now know there are leaked state
department memos where they told biden
uh the taliban are going to take over
right away biden wanted a cheap
political win before september 11th
that's what it was so they didn't take
five seconds to think about getting out
our civilians maybe destroying our
military equipment so they don't fall
into the hands of the people we've spent
20 years fighting it was all about
politics it's all politics all the time
that's why he's changing the subject now
to coronavirus in the infrastructure
bill they only think about politics
never about america never about
americans and why aren't our rangers and
our special operators who are over there
right now and our marines why aren't
they making gun runs out there grabbing
our civilians the french are doing it
the british are doing it our guys are
chomping at the bit to do it they're
stuck in the airport scratching their
rear ends while our citizens are out
there running for their lives this
entire administration is a disgrace
that's a great question why we're not
doing that robin you come from the world
of politics you are an obama campaign
advisor so is jesse right everything
that has been done here all the chaos
that has ensued a byproduct of president
biden choosing political motivations
no and i say that because i i take him
at his word he said i'll take that
criticism if it means bringing our men
and women home alive
i as a veteran army ranger i appreciate
that i just want to say you know
intellectual honesty is important in
these times uh and intellectual that
means that we'll we're not going to know
what ranger regiment is doing because
that's secret we're not going to know
what special forces is doing because
that's secret they could very well be
doing because these gun runs we will not
know about it until these soldiers are
back home safely jesse last word to you
look will this is the problem we have
right now in the entire government it's
not it's not isolated to the biden
administration honestly he owns this the
military owns this the intelligence
community owns this what i want to see
from one person is accountability
here here
all right robin jesse uh thank you both
for your service by the way army ranger
marine on this panel thank you both and
thanks for being with me tonight
thank you
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else